talk to me about your reaction when you
read the script for your final episode
but why I was I was really pleased with
the Game of Thrones has come and gone
and like many out there I was deeply
disappointed in how the final season
shaped up and I'm not the only one I
hate Dumb and Dumber the producers and
writers of the show I have never liked
them they are the most overrated
egotistical sorry excuses for talent in
Hollywood as of the making of this video
the petition to rewrite season 8 is
approaching a staggering one-and-a-half
million signatures that's like more than
the petition to end world hunger but
it's one thing to hate the season it's
another to claim you could have written
it better so before you go ahead and
automatically dislike this video
hear me out if you don't like what I'm
putting down fair enough
but the whole reason I'm making this
video is because I love this show so
much and felt the characters deserved a
lot better I'm splitting this video into
two distinct halves first my two major
critiques of the season and two the
rewrite so if you're interested in just
the rewrite portion I've left the
timestamp in the description below but
keep in mind my critique of the season
informs the rewrite a few ground rules
before we begin this is going to be a
broad overarching revision of some of
the main tentpole moments not a
scene-by-scene rewrite or else we'd be
here all day in fact I'm leaving
episodes 1 & 2 relatively untouched
opting to start with episode 3 where
things started to go downhill for me and
then onward to episode 4 where things
went completely off the rails while
Danny kind of forgot about the iron
fleet and Euron's forces and I'm also
not going to magically add episodes or
seasons I want to give myself the same
constraints the showrunners hat even
though the last 35 minutes of the final
episode arguably could have been an
entire season in and of itself so I'm
gonna briefly go over what I believe the
two major problems of this season were
now I know there are literally hundreds
of things to [ __ ] about this season and
I could do a video entirely just on that
but for the purposes of my rewrite I'm
gonna focus just on these two major
points
one the night king and two character
arcs the night king is the main
antagonistic force that propels much of
the narrative in the show it's his
presence that forces people like Danny
and John to band together in order to
save humanity if the night king is
successful in his quest then it doesn't
matter who's on the Iron Throne I argue
that the night King is more important of
a foe than Cersei and there's more at
stake should our heroes fail against him
look all the way back at the very first
scene in the very first season it
doesn't start with the death of Jon
Arryn palace intrigue or something to do
with the throne it starts with the White
Walkers that's how important day and the
night King are this is why the night
king dying in Episode three was a major
mistake not only were we denied an epic
battle between Jon and the night king
which was essentially promised to us
with the end of hardhome but all eight
seasons of the show have been building
up to this moment will they defeat the
night king or not by having him die in
episode three you lose eight seasons of
that tension the best analogy I can make
is imagine if Frodo dropped the ring
into Mount Doom and defeated Sauron
halfway through the two towers the most
climactic moment of the series should be
continually built upon until it explodes
near the final 10% of the show or film
take a look at this diagram which shows
the traditional three-act structure of a
movie the same applies for a TV series
just in those instances it stretched out
across episodes this is where the defeat
of the night king should have happened
here is where it did keep this in mind
when I go over my rewrite the second
major critique I have of the season are
the character arcs mainly because many
of them a didn't live up to their
potential or B were disregarded entirely
now that isn't to say some characters
didn't receive proper arcs I thought sir
Jorah and Theon both received endings
that made sense both narrative ly and
emotionally but then there are
characters like john danny and the one
who had the most potential Jamie
Lannister
Jaime had the most compelling arc over
the eight seasons starting as an
incestuous child murderer who over the
span of eight seasons learns the error
of his ways and becomes humble yet in
the show's final episodes he reverts
back to his old self and his love for
circe takes over eight seasons of
building this change within him even
banging Brianne was thrown under the bus
so he could die to a pile of falling
rubble this unrealized potential of
character arcs is something I want to
address in the rewrite so without
further ado this is how I would have
written the final season of Game of
Thrones okay enough of that we start
with episode three the Battle of
Winterfell and for the most part this
episode will play out much like it did
in the real version the combined forces
of the unsullied a frackie Northman and
wildlings face off against the night
King and his undead horde meanwhile
Cersei the golden company and the iron
fleet chill in King's Landing
having reneged on their promise to help
in the upcoming war but this episode
will have one major difference that will
completely change the episodes to come
the night king will be victorious and
the remaining forces of Winterfell will
be forced to retreat to King's Landing
let's dig a little deeper how this would
play out first I wouldn't put Tyrion the
women and children in the crypt yes it's
fun to have them in danger from the
rising corpses of the stark family but
it's lazy writing they are putting the
thrill of having to dodge Tommy's above
logic as Peter Dinklage says nobody
thought of that he's bringing all the
dead people back to life and they put
the women and children in a crypt with
all the dead people so instead I'd move
them to the main hall where later Tyrion
and the others are confronted with the
fact they will soon die it's like the
scene in the two towers when the battle
looks lost and we see the pain of the
women and children embracing each other
one final time you can still have Taran
and Sansa holding hands than Tyrion
picking up a blade ready to fight and
even Sansa ready to join him in their
last hurrah it's emotional visceral and
gets the point across without mummies
rising from the dead meanwhile Danny and
Jon would be taking on the night king
with their dragons but as the battle
intensifies Jon has to split from Dany
to help the soldiers below not only that
but he'll have to decide between saving
bran or fending off the zombie hordes
about to break in and kill Tyrion and
Sansa but Theon who's with bran tells
Jon to go he'll hold them off down there
and Jon a Drago's smash
to the side of the main hall just in
time to save the women and children
giving them the opportunity to escape
through winter fells underground tunnels
underground tunnels which will have a
spattering of undead for them to fend
off but then we can get characters like
aria who would join them in providing
much-needed protection as they make
their escape Dani hearing Reagan's cries
would muster enough strength to dismount
the knight King from Vissarion plunging
him to the ground just like what
happened in the original John would then
make his way to the weirwood tree just
in time to see a Theon fall to the night
king this death would fuel an emotional
John to attack and we finally get a
sword battle between John and the knight
king trust me it'll be epic but the
making will prove too powerful for John
eventually gaining the upper hand sword
at their ready to kill him when bran
suddenly wargs into Viserion breathing
dragon fire all over the knight king yes
in my version bran actually uses his
powers that actually helps them but the
knight king emerges from the fire much
like he did in the original unscathed by
the flames and now holding a dragonglass
spear he slays Viserion which causes the
largest and most epic disintegration
we've seen yet taking this brief moment
of opportunity John musters the strength
for one last attack and stabs the night
king with his dragonglass sword but
nothing happens the night King we find
is impervious to dragonglass it's a huge
shock to John who is quickly picked up
by the throat much like arya was and
when all seems lost for john Danny
swoops in on Drogo and knocks the night
king about 20 feet away freeing John
with the battle loss she grabs Jon and
bran Winterfell burning in the
background as we see regal overrun and
killed the episode would end with the
Risen dead Dothraki unsullied and all
those who perished in a battle rising
from the dead as the night King
continues his conquest south as John
looks to brand will find that bran is
stuck in his war expand they're unable
to snap him out of it we'll get to what
he's actually doing it a bit what I like
about this is that it keeps the tension
of the night King attacks still at play
while giving us a shocking new piece of
information that dragonglass doesn't
work against him it raises the stakes
for the next even bigger attack on
King's Landing if I'm gonna keep
comparing this to Lord of the Rings
episode 3 is the two towers and episode
5 is
Return of the King episode 4 would be
re-written to deal with the fallout of
the battle as the remaining survivors
hastily scrambled to King's Landing it's
here that Cersei will have to decide
whether or not to let them in and it's
Jaime who convinces her along with
reports that Chiron receives on the
encroaching dead army Cersei agrees to
let them in she doesn't really have a
choice here but on one condition
as long as Danny bends the knee publicly
for all to see and with Cersei holding
all the power here and Danny's army
almost completely wiped out
Dany agrees she puts her people before
herself she sacrifices everything for
the safety of her kin episode 5 just
like the original would be an attack on
King's Landing but instead of it being a
one-sided massacre it would be an epic
battle much like that of ministereth in
Lord of the Rings one of the things I
disliked about the original was that it
wasn't really a battle at all the golden
company didn't do anything John didn't
do anything
I felt it had so much unrealized
potential so we're gonna try to fix that
as the night king approaches his main
forces line up along the outer walls but
the night king is smart and has a
separate force along the water's edge as
the temperature drops the water around
Euron's fleet starts to freeze allowing
the White Walkers access to the port
making the defending army have to defend
from two fronts even worse is that we'll
see Dothraki on undead horses undead
unsullied and a bunch of undead Giants
joined the battle for the night King as
well but as the defenses of King's
Landing begin to fall bran awakens from
his dreamlike state as the three-eyed
Raven he spent this time since the fall
of Winterfell going back in time
searching for clues that could reveal
the Night Kings weakness and those Clues
lie in the messages and symbols we've
seen going back to season 1 he notifies
Dany and this could be shown through a
series of flashbacks like it has been
with bran in the past that the night
king is linked to the children of the
forest remember that the night king was
created by them in a place called gods
eye when he was tied up against the
great weirwood tree bear with me as I go
into a little bit of nerdy G ot lore
here the grandeur great weirwood tree is
the heart of all the where woods in
Westeros and in my version is the source
of the night king
power after all it created him why can't
it destroy him as well Danny is told
that if she destroys it it may also have
the added consequence of destroying
every type of magic in the world
destroying the grand weirwood tree would
also kill John after all the only reason
John is still alive was that he was
revived using magic by Melisandre to
make matters worse since bran was marked
by the night king the night king now
knows what they're up to and will likely
himself be on his way to protect the
tree Danny goes to John as the castle
walls are crumbling and tells him what
she has to do and John being the
understanding and compassionate soldier
understands but Danny is the one who's
more torn here not because she'll lose
John but that shall lose the father to
her child yes in my version Danny is
pregnant upping the stakes about ten
notches she flies off with drogue on to
the grand weirwood tree is the remaining
forces of King's Landing fight on it's
he or she's confronted by the night king
in an epic final showdown
the real Battle of Ice and Fire and the
only thing standing before her in the
tree is the night king himself she
confronts him and before he attacks
she'll stir chorus burning her the night
king and the grand weirwood tree all
together and as the tree burns so does
the night Kings flesh she takes her
sword and stabs the night king through
the heart piercing him into the burning
tree just like he was pierced in the
heart by the children of the forest
centuries ago and this is all happening
as Danny herself is being burned but as
we know she can withstand flames she's
just never had to endure flames of this
strength before and as the night king is
dying so does Jon and the undead what I
like about this particular ending is
that it makes the theory that the night
King would die by dragon fire true just
not in the way we envisioned it it also
ties in and brings back all those
children of the four symbols we've seen
throughout the seasons which in the
current version turned out meant nothing
at all nothing at all nothing but where
does that leave us with the other
characters we still have Cersei the
mountain you're on and countless others
don't worry we can still have
cleganebowl and you're on I'd have
killed by the white walkers
but then there's Cersei ah yes Cersei
imagine this the battle is over we
follow Jaime on his way to Cersei we're
not
he's gonna kill her and that adds to the
tension in the halls of King's Landing
completely out of the blue a Laureus and
emerges and stabs him in the chest
you'll remember ilaria was stuck in the
dungeon and forced to watch her
daughter's slowly be poisoned to death
by the Lannisters it was also the
Lannisters responsible for her lover
oberyn's death in season 4
she's broken free either by an ally
letting her out or garnering her escape
through the destruction caused by the
attack but as Jaime clings to life it's
revealed it isn't Jaime at all
it's Arya using Jaime's face as a mask
to kill the Queen ilaria recoils in
shock as Arya spits up blood don't worry
we'll see Arya survive and go off on her
adventures but I thought it would be a
cool way to bring back her assassin
training bring back ilaria and provide a
fun twist then we have the showdown
between the real Jaime and Cersei Cersei
tells him that it's finally over they've
won the throne and the battle of the
undead Dany in the northern army have
all but been destroyed and nothing
stands in their way
but Cersei won't stop there now the
battle is over she says she must send a
signal a decisive blow she calls for the
murder of anyone who was loyal to
Daenerys Jaime pleads on their behalf
without them they never would have
survived and besides is this the type of
new world they want their child to grow
up in and it's here Cersei divulges
there never was a baby it was all part
of playing the game to simultaneously
keep him and Euron in check she tells
him to go ahead and kill them all a
throwback to Aerys Targaryen the Mad
King when he wanted the city to burn and
it's here Jaime completes his arc
plunging his sword into Cersei and
killing her for good the Kingslayer is
now also the queen Slayer Danny arrives
back and rushes to Jon laying by his
side but it's too late King's Landing is
in ruins with no one to rule a crowd has
formed around her in the dead body of
Jon Tyrion tells the by standards of
Jon's heritage and how Dany now with
Jon's child makes her the rightful heir
to the throne
Tyrion kneels before his queen and
hundreds of men and women around kneel
as well she makes her way to the throne
and sits as we cut to black but just
because we can make it a little more
emotional we'll do something
Game of Thrones hasn't done before hey I
can break the rules right let's flash
forward five years
Daenerys visits the crypts of Winterfell
and by the way Winterfell has been
rebuilt with Sansa as protector of the
North in the crypts Jon's body has been
placed next to edit and Catelyn and who
happens to come rushing through but
their son we can even throw in ghosts in
here too she puts her hand on the tomb
and walks away calling for her son
saying come along John I like this
because it does away with the whole
powers of Westeros choosing the new king
not to mention bran becoming King which
I thought was problematic we also have
more fulfilling character arcs for John
Dany and Jaime now I couldn't get to all
the characters but I invite you to leave
your comments below on what you would
have liked to have seen this season for
me this ending gives me what I want it's
more traditional heightens the stakes of
the night King and provides more
fulfilling arcs for many of her beloved
characters if you liked this video
please take a moment to like subscribe
and let me know what you think until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much